so my dad doesn't know about my personal
dating life right because I don't share
any of that [ __ ] with him I don't want
to just because he's super noisy and
kind of annoying and at that time I
didn't really get along with him so
anything that I would tell him he would
just spin it out of control and he'll
give you advice and try to control you
and all that exactly so one time this is
during the time I was a youth minister
at this church that he started up so I
get there and after church my dad's like
hey I want to introduce you to somebody
and I'm like who who do you want to
introduce me to and he goes I want to
introduce you to girl night nah I'm good
he goes no no it's nothing like that
like I just want you to hang out I just
see her she's new in town hang and this
girl looked like she bench-pressed like
at least she was like a rugby player
dude she was buff she was just like
thick you know anybody got against
swimmers she was she she looked like the
golfer she had the Hat she was wearing a
hoodie and and hallo shirt and all her I
was like I guess she's she might be a
sweet girl whatever right I'm not gonna
try to go on a date with her but this
will try to set me up at a blind date at
church with her parents right there so I
couldn't say no so I I said okay cool
like I'll take her out around town or
whatever says she's new to the area yeah
so check this [ __ ] out I can't I cannot
make this [ __ ] up so is probably feeling
like that too
probably she's like [ __ ] my parents so
you will see this right so one day so
when I would do my ministry at the
church the after that I would go to
another church to get my own sermon you
know and a different church and those
one in Davis so this girl if she wanted
to go to Davis and she goes hey can you
know can I come along with you to go to
church after and I was like all right
cool so I got kind of blindsided on this
blind date so we go there the church is
closed and you know it's really awkward
conversations and this is on the drive
back so in the drive back all of a
sudden I we're driving and I turn turn
on some music she goes to my music not
but she dials all the music that she
turns it off why I don't know she's
honest I guess but she just turned the
music down say okay that was a little
weird and I kinda like turn it up a
little bit she shuts it right off again
and I'm like what okay this is a little
weird and as we're driving I don't
remember what she's saying verbatim
because it's happened quite if
years ago but it would be like some [ __ ]
where she just sitting there just say
yeah I don't I don't want to do no no
don't don't do this to me what are you
doing right now I stop she's talking to
herself and I'm like the [ __ ] do this
mist and so I looked over I was like oh
she's mine as a Bluetooth in her ear
right so I kind of ignored it and she no
stop stop
don't don't don't do this and I'm like I
look over there's nothing in her ear
she's [ __ ] talking to herself oh [ __ ]
talking to herself and I'm like yo are
you okay like who are you talking to
right she goes oh I kind of don't want
to talk about this right now
and I'm like well don't you want to talk
about like are you cool are you ok
because I wanted to see if I need to
pull over so [ __ ] and I'm in the middle
of the freeway this is a long-ass
freeway from Davis to Sacramento yeah
yeah you took her on a long as road trip
I was like 35 minutes 40 minutes yeah no
that's how far I used to go to go to
church and then she would just be like
then she when she did this [ __ ] she goes
yeah she goes I'm talking to my
ex-boyfriend right now and I'm like oh
like like well you got a Bluetooth or
some [ __ ] and she goes no he speaks
speaks to me telepathically bro I'm not
making this [ __ ] [ __ ] up if she goes
he's speaking to me telepathically and
I'm and bro I'm laughing she was joking
and like connection like the Avatar tog
so I started cracking up I thought she
was busting the joke and look at her
deadpan not a joke and I'm like yo but
to scare you so you don't [ __ ] come
on to her so I thought she was like kind
of [ __ ] around or whatever yeah and
then she goes yeah like so if he goes if
you look at my boyfriend's eyes he she
goes one of his eyes is it's like steel
cold grey and a split half in blue and
that shows that he knows he knows
telepathy he goes when I was when I was
we used to live together and I I'm just
telling him right now to leave me alone
because the last time I was with him he
was talking to me he made me burn down a
house bro I started sweating I thought
she was going I thought she was gonna
take the wheel and then [ __ ] throw us
off on the freeway so I was sweating
[ __ ] bullets holding the wheel super
tight and I turned the music and I
should turn it down again she goes I
can't hear him um she's like yelling at
me at this point
like yo what the [ __ ] is going on right
now that at that point I was so [ __ ]
scared cuz she kept on telling me the
stories I don't remember them all right
now I might be able to Recoleta later if
I really think about it but she was
telling me the story about how she like
telepathically controlled her yeah and
had her burned down the house that they
were staying at yeah and then she had a
she burned another house that she loves
burning else's yeah he's talking to me
she's like and as words she's telling
the story she goes shut up shut up shut
up shut up Oh tongue and so I'm freaking
out I finally get to her house at the
driveway I drop her off like hey it's
nice meeting you like I'll hit you up
some other time she goes well let me get
your number I don't know
oh [ __ ] and at this point I was thinking
to myself I should give her a fake
number I was like you should I give her
a fake number my real number yeah and so
I was like I should probably give her my
real number just in case so I gave her
my real number right and as and she
leaves and as I'm backing out she calls
my phone's looking into my car she goes
oh I just wanted to see if this was a
fake number oh and I Drive back I go to
my dad yeah and I'm like yo what the
[ __ ] was that I was like how the [ __ ] I
was like did you know she's like a
schizophrenic she's talking to human
beings in her head and all my dad goes
oh that's so funny and he says he starts
dying laughing he pranked you know he
didn't know but he just thought it was
so funny I was like dawg
she could've [ __ ] killed me dude Wow
so she was so what I found out later on
was that she was trying to go I guess
she's been trying to get into the Navy
or whatever but she couldn't pass like a
psych eval obviously dude she's [ __ ]
crazy turns out she wasn't schizophrenic
she was like dealing with like
schizophrenia and her you know like
Asian parents they don't believe in
mental illness they're like oh she's
just a little weird she's a [ __ ]
schizophrenic it may be [ __ ] no oh
[ __ ] so they they saw this obviously
this behavior might be happening in the
house yeah so they were just trying to
keep it under wraps I guess and I guess
for them kind of what I'm concluding
they're probably like thank God David
okay take her ass and Mariel
I got her out of the [ __ ] house I got
[ __ ] pissed so my dad talked to their
parents yeah and this is why I'm
assuming I assumed that she just gets a
frantic because she's talking to people
or whatever whatnot
and then my dad was explained to me
after as he's laughing and this is this
is after he laughed the first time this
is the second time because I talked to
them and I guess she's you know she
like some issues here and there I was
like that's not some issues they refuse
to recognize that she has a mental
illness yeah she needs help she needs
[ __ ] help and they she set me up on a
blind date with the schizophrenic dude
yeah
one of the worst blind dates I ever have
that she laughed at [ __ ] died spa
shut up shut up shut up
that's [ __ ] scary he's talking to me
right now my ex-boyfriend hold on
no I don't wanna order pizza yeah yes
[ __ ] I feel like yes half half gray eyes
and half believed or green didn't even
have an ex-boyfriend that's what I'm
saying I don't even think she did but
she's like but she was saying that he
was he was talking to her telepathically
and the last time they were they were
together he would control her mind and
had her burned down her name her
neighbor's house or some [ __ ] that is
[ __ ] crazy see that's the part of
dating that I don't like is like you
don't know these people and they could
be the sweetest cuz you know everyone
has [ __ ] baggage like all of our
friends all of our family members
everyone has something wrong with them
or some issue that they're dealing with
right that eventually is gonna spill on
to you and whatever your issues are is
gonna spill onto them I it's crazy
because I went on when I was so after my
first girlfriend and I broke up I kind
of had this whole thing I did a whole
little miniseries and people want me to
continue which I might the where uh I I
I kind of focus only on one girl in high
school because I was such a [ __ ]
loser and after that I was like I'm
gonna date anybody and everybody just
because I don't even know what I like I
want to I want to do the exact opposite
of this [ __ ] girl and just date
whoever but because I have so many
random dating stories because I I think
I [ __ ] you not when I came back from
Riverside and I started going to
Community College any opportunity that
could date somebody I started dating
people specifically because I wanted
stand-up stories because I noticed that
my stand-up was so [ __ ] weak and I
kept on doing Asian jokes and which
which was they were hitting at the time
but it was I was kind of biting off of
like just all these Asian stereotypes
which I molded it well but it was like I
wanted to speak more than that so I
started dating cuz I thought you know I
think relationship stuff and dating
stuff is very relatable
I started dating every [ __ ] girl so I
don't like a thousand [ __ ] stories I
haven't written him in a notebook
somewhere big of my old stand up of all
these weird dating situations that was
one of them was when my dad set me on a
[ __ ] blind date with the
schizophrenic that's pretty crazy that
was one of the war situations I've ever
[ __ ] been in and it's so hard to tell
cuz like it almost sounds [ __ ]
unbelievable but yeah just ask my
[ __ ] dad and he'll probably crack up
as you mention the story to him it was
[ __ ] cry I still remember what she
looks like till this day white [ __ ]
hoodie wrapped up in her head white golf
cap the [ __ ] the faded blue jeans the
white Skechers and then she had her
hoodie tied in a knot
no like up here and it was super tight
around her head [ __ ] man that's some
serial killer sure issue the the what
she wore at church was the same thing
that she wore the day that we went out
and did she changing clothes she didn't
change clothes she just wore the same
outfit so when you guys were on the way
there she was fine and you guys were
doing the whole praise circle or
whatever everything was fine oh so we
couldn't go into the church because I
guess there was like a holiday then and
and then church was closed Oh time and
it got shifted to another time so he
missed sermons so he went all the way
back so I just drove the Davis and I
drove all oh yeah and she's dog and the
only reason I know about the whole Navy
stuff that she was trying to get into
the Navy because the conversation there
was perfectly fine she was talking about
her wanting to get the Navy and also the
shed or II she didn't have a granola bar
or something and she started freaking
out I don't know what the [ __ ] that was
but that [ __ ] was crazy because when she
was talking to talking to herself I
thought she was talking on a Bluetooth
yeah that [ __ ] does [ __ ] with people
that wouldn't you know the Bluetooth
when it started coming out I was like so
many people talking to themselves yeah
[ __ ]
or like sedale say [ __ ] and I'm all like
yes and I'm like oh look man [ __ ] you
know I've had so many [ __ ] weird
dating